this video is about correlation analysis
we start by asking what a correlation
analysis is we will then look at the
most important correlation analysis
Pearson correlations Spearman
correlation candles Tau and Point by
zero correlation and finally we will
discuss the difference between
correlation and causation let's start
with the first question what is a
correlation analysis correlation
analysis is a statistical method used to
measure the relationship between two
variables for example is there a
relationship between a person's salary
and age
in this scatter plot every single point
is a person in correlation analysis we
usually want to know two things number
one how strong the correlation is at
number two in which direction the
correlation goes
we can read both in the correlation
coefficient which is between
-1 and 1. the strength of the
correlation can be read in a table if R
is between 0 and 0.1 we speak of no
correlation if R is between
0.7 and 1 we speak of a very strong
correlation a positive correlation
exists when high values of one variable
go along with high values of the other
variable or when small values of one
variable go along with small values of
the other variable a positive
correlation is found for example for
body size and shoe size the result is a
positive correlation coefficient a
negative correlation exists when high
values of one variable go along with low
values of the other variable and vice
versa a negative core relation usually
exists between product price and sales
volume the result is a negative
correlation coefficient
now we have different correlation
coefficients the most popular are
Pearson correlation coefficient are
spiem and correlation coefficient RS
candles Tau and Point by zero
correlation coefficient rpb let's start
with the first the Pearson correlation
coefficient what is the Pearson
correlation as all correlation
coefficients the Pearson correlation R
is a statistical measure that quantifies
the relationship between two variables
in the case of Pearson correlation the
linear relationship of Matrix variables
is measured more about metric variables
later so with the help of piercing
correlation we can measure the linear
relationship between two variables and
of course the Pearson correlation
coefficient R tells us how strong the
correlation is and in which direction
the correlation goes how how is peace
and correlation calculated the Pearson
correlation coefficient is obtained via
this equation where R is the Pearson
correlation coefficient x i are the
individual values of one variable for
example h y i are the individual values
of the other variable for example salary
x dash and Y dash are respectively the
mean values of the two variables in the
equation we can see that the respective
mean value is first subtracted from both
values so in our example we calculate
the mean values of H and salary we then
subtract the mean values from each
person's age and salary
then we multiply both values and we sum
up the individual results of the
multiplication the expression in the
denominator ensures that the correlation
coefficient is scaled between
-1 and 1. if we now multiply two
positive values we get a positive value
so all values that lie in this area have
a positive influence on the correlation
coefficient if we multiply two negative
values we also get a positive value
minus times minus is plus so all values
that lie in this area also have a
positive influence on the correlation
coefficient if we multiply a positive
value and a negative value we get a
negative value minus times plus is minus
so all values that lie in these ranges
have a negative influence on the
correlation coefficient therefore if our
values are predominantly in these two
areas we get a positive correlation
coefficient and thus a positive
relationship if our values are
predominantly in these two areas we get
a negative correlation coefficient and
thus a negative relationship if the
points are distributed over all four
areas the positive terms and the
negative terms cancel each other out and
we get a very small or no correlation
but now there's one more thing to
consider the correlation coefficient is
usually calculated with data taken from
a sample however we often want to test a
hypothesis about the population in the
case of correlation analysis we then
want to know if if there is a
correlation in the population for this
we check whether the correlation
coefficient in the sample is
statistically significantly different
from zero the null hypothesis in the
Pearson correlation is the correlation
coefficient does not differ
significantly from zero there is no
linear relationship and the alternative
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient differs significantly from
zero there is a linear relationship
attention it is always tested whether
the null hypothesis is rejected or not
in our example the research question is
is there a correlation between age and
salary in the British population
to find out we draw a sample and test
whether in this sample the correlation
coefficient is significantly different
from zero the null hypothesis then is
there is no correlation between salary
and age in the British population and
the alternative hypothesis there is a
correlation between salary and age in
the British population whether the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero based on the sample
collected can be checked using a t-test
where R is the correlation coefficient
and N is the sample size a p-value can
then be calculated from the test
statistic T if the p-value is smaller
than the specified significance level
which is usually five percent then the
null hypothesis is rejected otherwise it
is not but what about the assumptions
for a piercing correlation here we must
distinguish whether we just want to
calculate the Pearson correlation or
whether we want to test a hypothesis to
calculate the piece of correlation
coefficient only two metric variables
need to be present metric variables are
for example a person's weight a person's
salary or electricity consumption the
Pearson correlation coefficient then
tells us how large the linear
relationship is if there is a non-linear
relationship we cannot tell from the
Pearson correlation coefficient however
if we want to test whether the piercing
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero the two variables
must always be normally distributed if
this is not given the calculated test
statistic t or the p-value cannot be
interpreted reliably let's continue with
the Spearman correlation the Spearman
rank correlation is the non-parametric
counterpart of the Pearson correlation
but there is an important difference
between both correlation coefficient
regions Spearman correlation does not
use the raw data but the ranks of the
data let's look at this with an example
we measure the reaction time of 8
computer players and ask their age when
we calculate a Pearson correlation we
simply take the two variables reaction
time and age and calculate the Pearson
correlation coefficient however we now
want to calculate the Spearman rank
correlation so first we assign a rank to
each person for reaction time and age
the reaction time is already sorted by
size
12 is the smallest value so gets rank 1
15 the second smallest value so it gets
Rank 2 and so on and so forth we are now
doing the same with age here we have the
smallest value there the second smallest
they are the third smallest fourth
smallest and so on and so forth let's
take a look at this in the Scatter Plots
here we see the raw data of age and
three action time but now we would like
to use the rankings so we form ranks
from the variables age and reaction time
through this transformation we have now
distributed the data more evenly to
calculate the Pearson correlation we
simply calculate the Pearson correlation
from the ranks so the Spearman
correlation is equal to the Pearson
correlation only that the ranks are used
instead of the raw values let's have a
quick look at that in data tab here we
have the reaction time and age and there
we have the chest created ranks of
reaction time and age now we can either
calculate spewing correlation of
reaction time and age where we get a
correlation of 0.9
or we can calculate Pearson correlation
from the ranks where we also get 0.9 so
exactly the same as before if you like
you can download the data set you can
find the link in the video description
if there are no rank ties we can also
use this equation to calculate the
Pearson correlation RS is the spumin
correlation n is the number of cases and
D is the difference in ranks between the
two variables referring to our example
we get a different D's with this one
minus 1 is equal to zero two minus three
is minus one three minus two is one and
so on now we Square the individual D's
and add them all up so the sum of d i
squared is eight n which is the number
of people is eight if you put everything
in we get a correlation coefficient of
0.9 just like the Pearson correlation
coefficient R spiem and correlation
coefficient RS also varies between
-1 and 1. let's continue with candles
Tau candles tau is the correlation
coefficient and this does a measure of
the relationship between two variables
but what is the difference between
Pearson correlation and canvas rank
correlation in contrast to Pearson
correlation candles rank correlation is
a non-parametric test procedure thus for
the calculation of candlestow the data
need not be normally distributed and the
variables need only have ordinal scale
levels exactly the same is true for the
Spearman rank correlation right that's
right
candles towel is very similar to
spearman's rank correlation coefficient
however candle's Tau should be preferred
over spearman's correlation if very few
data with many ranked ties are available
but how is candlestar calculated we can
calculate candle Style with this formula
where C is the number of concordant
pairs and D is the number of discordant
pairs what are concordant and discordant
pairs we will now go through this with
an example suppose two doctors are asked
to rank six patients according to their
physical health one of the two doctors
is now defined as a reference and the
patients are sorted from 1 to 6. now the
sorted ranks are matched with the ranks
of the other doctor EG the patient who
is in third place with the reference
doctor is enforced place with the other
doctor now using candlestow we want to
know if there is a correlation between
the two rankings for the calculation of
candles Tau we only need these ranks we
now look at each individual Rank and
note whether the values below are
smaller or greater than itself so we
start at the first Rank 3 1 is smaller
than 3 so gets a minus 4 is greater so
gets a plus two is smaller so it gets a
minus 6 is greater so it gets a plus and
5 is also greater so it also gets a plus
now we do the same for one here of
course each subsequent rank is greater
than one so we have a plus everywhere at
Rank 4 2 is smaller and six and five are
greater now we do this for Rank 2 and
rank 6. then we can easily calculate the
number of concordant and discordant
pairs we get the number of concordant
pairs by counting all the Plus in our
example we have 11 plus in total we get
a number of discordant pairs by counting
through all the minus in our example we
have a total of four minus C is thus 11
and D is 4. candlest Tau now is 11 minus
four divided by 11 plus 4 and we get a
candle style of
0.47 we get an alternative formula for
candle style here with s is C minus D
therefore 7 n is the number of cases ie6
if we insert everything we also get 7
divided by 15. just like the Pearson
correlation coefficient R candles Tau
also varies between
-1 and plus one we have again calculated
correlation coefficient using data from
a sample now we can test if the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero thus the null
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient tau is equal to zero there
is no relationship and the alternative
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient tau is n equal to zero there
is a relationship therefore we want to
know if the correlation coefficient is
significantly different from zero you
can analyze this either by hand or with
a software like data tab for the
calculation by hand we can use the set
distribution as an approximation however
for this we should at least have 40
cases so the six cases from our example
are actually too few we get the set
value with this formula here we have Tau
and N is the number of cases this brings
us to the last correlation analysis the
point by zerial correlation Point by
zero correlation is a special case of
Pearson correlation and examines the
relationship between a dichotomous
variable and the metric variable what is
a dichotomous variable and what is a
metric variable at Economist variable is
a variable with two values for example
gender with male and female or smoking
status with smoker and non-smoker a
matrix variable is for example the
weight of a person the salary of a
person or the electricity consumption so
if we have a dichotomous variable and a
metric variable and we want to know if
there is a relationship we can use a
Point by zero correlation of course we
need to check the assumptions beforehand
but more about that later how is the
point the serial correlation calculated
as stated at the beginning the point by
zero correlation is a special case of
the Pearson correlation but how can we
calculate the PSN correlation when a
variable is nominal let's look at this
with an example let's say we are
interested in investigating the
relationship between the number of hours
studied for a test and the test result
passed failed with calculated data from
a sample of 20 students where 12
students pass the test and eight
students failed we have recorded the
number of hours each student studied for
the test to calculate the point by zero
correlation we first need to convert the
test result into numbers we can assign a
score of 1 to students who pass the test
and the score of zero to students who
failed the test now we can either
calculate the Pearson correlation of
time and test results or we use the
equation for the point by zero and
correlation X1 Dash is the mean value of
the people who have passed and X2 Dash
is the mean value of the people who
failed N1 is the number of people who
passed and N2 the number of people who
failed and N is the total number but
whether we calculate the piercing
correlation or we use the equation for
the point by zerial correlation we get
the same result both times let's take a
quick look at this in data tab here we
have the learning hours the test result
was passed and failed and there the test
result was 0 and 1. we Define the test
result with 0 and 1 as metric
if we now go to correlation and
calculate the Pearson correlation for
these two variables we get a correlation
coefficient of 0.31 if we calculate the
point by zero correlation for learning
hours and exam result was passed and
failed we also get a correlation of 0.31
just like the Pearson correlation
coefficient R the point by zero
correlation coefficient rpb also varies
between
-1 and 1. if we have a coefficient
between -1 and less than 1 there is a
negative correlation thus a negative
relationship between the variables if we
have a coefficient between greater than
zero and one there is a positive
correlation that is a positive
relationship between the two variables
if the result is zero we have no
correlation as always with the Point by
zero correlation we can also check
whether the correlation coefficient is
significantly different from zero thus
the null hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient R is equal to zero there is
no relationship and the alternative
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient R is unequal to zero there
is a relationship before we get to the
assumptions here's an interesting note
when we compute a point by zeroid
correlation we get the same p-value as
when we compute a t-test for independent
samples for the same data so whether we
test a correlation hypothesis with the
point by zeroid correlation or a
difference hypothesis with the t-test we
get the same p-value now if we compute a
t-test in data tab with these data and
we have the null hypothesis there is no
difference between the groups field and
asked in terms of the variable learning
hours we get a p-value of
0.179 and also if we calculate a point
by zero correlation and have the null
hypothesis there is no correlation
between learning hours and test results
we get a p-value of
0.179 in our example the p-value is
greater than 0.05 which is most often
used as a significance level and thus
the null hypothesis is not rejected but
what about the assumptions for a point
by zero correlation here we must
distinguish whether we just want to
calculate the correlation coefficient or
whether we want to test a hypothesis to
calculate the correlation coefficient
only one metric variable and one
decadamus variable must be present
however if we want to test whether the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero the one metric
variable must also be normally
distributed if this is not given the
calculated test statistic t or the
p-value cannot be interpreted reliably
this brings us to the last question what
is causality and what is the difference
between causality and correlation
causality is the relationship between a
cause and an effect
in a causal relationship we have a cause
and a resultant effect an example coffee
contains caffeine a stimulating
substance when you drink coffee the
caffeine enters the body affects the
central nervous system and leads to
increased alertedness drinking coffee is
the cause of the feeling of alertedness
that comes afterwards without drinking
coffee the effect I.E the feeling of
alertedness would not occur but
causality is not always so easy to
determine clear requirements must be met
in order to speak of a cause and
relationship but more about that later
so what is the difference between
correlation and causality a correlation
tells us that there is a relationship
between two variables example there is a
positive correlation between ice cream
sales and a number of sunburns however
an existing correlation cannot tell us
which variable influences which or
whether a third variable is responsible
for the correlation in our example both
variables are influenced by a common
cause namely sunny weather on sunny days
people buy more ice cream and spend more
time Outdoors this can lead to an
increased risk of sunburns causality
means that there is a clear cause effect
relationship between two variables
causality exists when you can say with
certainty which variable influences
which however a common mistake in the
interpretation of Statistics is that a
correlation is immediately assumed to be
a causal relationship here is an example
the American statistician Daryl Huff
found a negative correlation between the
number of head lice and the body
temperature of the inhabitants of an
island a negative correlation means that
people with many head lice generally
have a lower body temperature and people
with few head lice generally have a
higher body temperature the island has
concluded that head lice were good for
health because the reduced fever so
their assumption was that headlights
have an effect on the temperature of the
body in reality the correct conclusion
is the other way around in an experiment
it was possible to prove that high fever
drives away life so the high body
temperature is the cause not the effect
what are the conditions for talking
about causality there are two conditions
for causality number one there is a
significant correlation between the
variables this is easy to check we
simply check whether the correlation
coefficient is significantly different
from zero row number two the second
condition can be met in three ways first
chronological sequence there is a
chronological sequence and the results
of one variable occurred before the
results of the other variable second
experiment a controlled experiment was
conducted in which the two variables can
be specifically influenced and number
three Theory there is a well-founded and
plausible theory in which direction the
causal relationship goes if there is
only a significant correlation but none
of the other three conditions are met we
can only speak of correlation never of
causality thanks for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the video